Speaker 1: So The David Pakman Show subreddit
has really been on fire, I think we have close to
34000 of our viewers and listeners subscribed. You
can find it at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit
and many interesting discussions happening every
day, a few of which I spotted this morning that I
wanted to highlight. User St. 500 posted My kids
school district in Missouri is closed for the
rest of this week due to staffing and attendance
issues. I got a letter from the school system.
Essentially, there's so many people sick that the
school had to close and this is a really important
thing. I know people in these situations as
well where the school is open in principle,
but then so many people, so many teachers are
sick that the school is closed until they can
find teachers, their teachers can recover from
COVID. Even when we have this discussion of should
schools be closed or not because of the virus, my
preference is for schools to be open. I agree with
everybody who says it's better for kids to be in
school in person who would deny that. The question
is by forcing them open. Do you really keep them
open? Because if they're open and 15 percent of
the teachers end up having to isolate quarantine
because they're either exposed or catch COVID,
and then you just don't have people, you don't
have staff, you don't have janitors, whatever,
and then you close anyway. What did we really gain
by having a couple of chaotic days in school? And
I'm hearing from tons of parents who are saying
that this exact thing is going on when people
started going back two weeks ago, one week ago. My
thought was, there's no way that this is going to
work in any real way. Either you're just going
to commit to the schools becoming superspreader
nodes or you'll be open a few days. And if you're
actually testing and have some kind of protocol,
you'll then just be forced to close and
it's happening just about everywhere. So
interesting that a lot of parents in the
audience are experiencing that. And again,
I think it's better for the schools to be open. We
want them open. It seems like it might have made
sense to do remote, maybe two or three weeks.
We see the Omicron wave already coming down
and we'll have those numbers for you. Probably
early next week. The numbers are looking better
and better. It probably made sense to just
do remote for a couple of weeks doesn't sound
completely crazy or devastating to the students,
and it would have prevented this insanity that's
going on now. A really very important post from
S.W. Frame, who said should the Democrats try
to get alacarte network TV in order to reduce the
impact of Fox News? Fox News is not ad supported.
Not completely. That's true. They charge the cable
networks more than other channels, which means all
subscribers indirectly fund the disinformation
spewing out of Fox News. Maybe Democrats should
get the cable networks to switch to ala carte
programs. I have been talking about this for
years. A ton of these networks function are
viable channels through bundling and and or
through charging really high fees. So when you
pay one hundred bucks for cable, you may or may
not know that certain amounts from that 100 bucks
go to specific channels or groups of channels.
Do you really think I'm making this up now? OK,
but do you really think that if imagine that
there was a bundle that's like golf one, two and
three HGTV one through four? And you know what? I
don't even know what these channels exist. Imagine
that it's like, OK, you got to pay us seven bucks
per subscriber for all seven of those channels.
Imagine that those were separated out, and instead
you could pay a dollar for each of those channels.
Do you think that many people are going to say, I
want to pay for HGTV one, two, three and four? Of
course not. Of course not. And much the same way,
if Fox News had a different deal where people
could say, I don't want Fox News and then they can
save three, four or five bucks, I don't know what
it is. Fox News loses a ton of money, and that's
exactly why they don't do it that way. So yes,
ala carte cable programing is something I've been
talking about for a really long time. It's there
with HBO. We know the technology exists. If you
don't want HBO, you don't pay for HBO. It's very,
very simple, considered a premium channel. If it
were, quite frankly, if it were that way for a lot
more channels, all of us would be saving money and
a lot of these channels would go out of business.
But yes, that's a very, very good idea. Lastly,
a user, Brian CRC, posted question for Trump rally
attendees. The Trump rally started up again over
the weekend. Can you name something new? You
learned for the rally and of course, from the
rally? And of course, the answer is no. Trump has
been doing the same stuff at the rallies basically
since Election Day, right? Saying I won and
information's coming out very soon, and the real
insurrection was January. It was. January it was
November of 2020 and all of this different stuff.
They are not there to learn anything new. They are
there to participate in the cult of personality.
And unless we understand that it's going to be
very difficult to prevent it from happening again,
and it is not about what he says, it is not
about learning anything. We need to understand
these people really for what they are, which is
quite frankly, cult members of a different sort,
a political cult. And I think that that would be
a really interesting quote. We've seen people do
interviews of Trump supporters at the rallies. It
would be great if someone on the way out stopped
people and said, What did you learn today that you
didn't know before? That would be a treasure trove
of fascinating interview material. I encourage
someone to do it. I don't want to be caught
dead near any of those rallies, particularly
because it seems really difficult to leave.
There was video from the rally in Florence,
Arizona, over the weekend of people saying
We were not. We're not being allowed to leave.
They're saying you need to wait until the full
Trump motorcade leaves. And then they were
allegedly letting all the vendors leave,
and there were people stuck for hours after the
rally. Imagine Trump's late to every rally drones
on for 90 to 120 minutes, and then you're not
even allowed to leave right away. Insane. I don't
want to go. Someone else wants to go and ask these
people what they've learned. I totally support it,
but I have no interest in being there. Join the
discussion at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.